-I want to talk about
"Sharp Objects,"
which I'm really enjoying,
but I hear you have a PSA,
you want to use this time...
-I do.
I do need to apologize to
a couple of people.
I've been meaning to do it over
several shows and appearances,
but um Christina Applegate.
-Okay.
Very, very famous actress.
-She's at the top
of my call list and I have fat
cheeks and I keep
accidentally calling her when I
smile during other phone calls.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-And then I don't say anything.
And I hang up.
Which is really rude, but it's
been like 300 times I think.
-Oh, whoa.
-Like, a lot.
Three-hundred times over the
course of...?
-Like two months.
-Okay, wow.
And so have you ever,
you abort before she picks up?
-I do, it's not nice
and so I apologize.
And then I think I've Facetimed
Jen Aniston on accident too.
From my bed, so.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Now, here's --
-I'm not sure it connected.
So who knows what happened
there.
-Now, here's the thing, because
both of them, I think,
probably have assumed that
you're calling them by accident.
-A-After about 30 times,
I would imagine.
-Yeah. But now, now,
that you've admitted it on TV,
the next time you do it
they're gonna be like,
"If she knows she's doing this."
-I'm gonna, I'm gonna say "Hi."
next time.
-Okay, good.
-But I don't know why,
I, like, lose my courage,
but I wanted to apologize,
so there.
I am very, very sorry,
it's very rude.
-That, uh, you should say,
"Christina,
this is very exciting,
this is your 300th call.
-[ Laughs ] I should just start
leaving messages,
like I've been
trying to reach her
and she hasn't been
calling me back or something.
You know, like, "It's been like
300 times, are you avoiding me?"
-Yeah. "I have run out gas
on the side of the road."
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
-Um, so you had not done --
Obviously you have
a very robust film career,
you have not done
a lot of television.
-Um, I have done television,
I just, not a lot of it
had made it to air.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
There yeah.
-Some of it got cancelled.
And I was also fired
from three shows.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Were they for three very
different reasons, or...?
-Three very different reasons.
-Okay gotcha. That's good.
-One, I was bad.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
You, looking back, do you agree
with that assessment or...?
-I mean, I was way too young,
it looked sort of -- yeah.
-Okay gotcha.
-But -- and it --
I was trying too hard.
And the other one...
just their actress became
available.
And then the other one,
I wasn't really fired,
but they brought in a really
tall blonde.
And I knew,
and they dyed my hair red,
and then I was fired for not
being sexy enough.
Rob Lowe writes about it
in his book.
They were right.
[ Laughter ]
I was not sexy enough,
they were right, so.
But yeah, so I thought my
relationship with television
was over and then
this came to me
and I was really,
really excited by the prospect
of coming back in this way.
-And you, obviously you --
you executive produced,
you had read this book.
-I had, yeah.
-By Gillian Flynn who wrote
"Gone Girl" as well.
-Yeah.
"Gone Girl" and, and
"Dark Places".
-And so, uh, the character is a
fairly dark character as well.
-Yeah.
-Did you, in reading the book,
did you think, "Oh, I want to
play this person"?
-I -- not when I was reading the
book because I-I had
read the book before they made
it into a series.
But when I saw the way they were
sort of stretching her out,
I -- it's just like where I was
in my life.
I thought it would be fun.
No, um...
[ Laughter ]
No, like, a real challenge to go
to a place like this
and sort of chall-- and test
myself as an actress.
And as a human being, like,
could I come back?